the single market and its tools are
always the solution or can be the
solution to the different challenges we
face in the European Union
instead of yeah 50 000 different
National norms and standards instead of
big customs declarations
European companies can just sell on
their products all over Europe and we as
consumers we profit from more choice but
also from lower prices next to the fact
that of course we also can move freely
work study live everywhere in the
European Union
foreign
at the moment we have this overall
challenge that is the war in Ukraine
High Energy prices inflation that are
having a lot of impact on businesses and
consumers in the European Union we saw
that especially during the pandemic the
last big crisis before the war Supply
chains were interrupted and borders were
closed again because of
yeah the virus that doesn't really stop
at the border
um so the internal Market always
basically I think needs to react to
those crisis needs to evolve and at the
end I would say the single market and
its tools
are always the solution or can be the
solution to the different challenges we
face in the European Union
[Music]
I think there is still a lot of Digital
Services that are not harmonized and
where there's still fragmentation going
on that makes it a little bit more
difficult to consumers or even
has basically safety gaps for consumers
so I think this is one important point I
think the second issue is that we need
to use digitalization much more better
for the green transition but also make
sure that with digitalization we don't
accelerate climate change for example
using green energy in the data centers
or and so on and so on is a very
important tool and then thirdly
I think we need to really start very
fast now with the DSA and the dma
implementation we see with the Takeover
of Twitter by Elon Musk and all the mess
it created that starting to implement
the DSA very fast and then also see
where it might be potential gaps and
then continue to improve it in the
future is important
foreign
was fighting very much for this we
finally have a solution and we will have
a common EU charger and it will help the
environment because we will save
resources but it will also help the
consumers because you don't have to
worry about different types of cables
you bring and different basically
electronic devices you have it will make
all of our Lives much easier